unser pressekonferenz darf die fraktion
mit unserem haushaltspolitischen
sprecher peter böhringer und dem
finanzpolitischen sprecher albrecht
glaser zum thema klage darf die fraktion
gegen die eu neuverschuldung und antrag
auf einstweilige anordnung beim
bundesverfassungsgericht
boehringer bitte an care schmidt denke
meine damen und herren fürs kommen auch
an den bildschirm ist bei der zahlreiche
eingeklickt wir haben sie aus aktuellem
anlass aber natürlich auch sehr
grundsätzlichen erwägungen heute zu
einer extra pressekonferenz her gebeten
in eineinhalb stunden wird im bundestag
eine der allerwichtigsten debatten in
dieser legislatur geführt werden um das
thema mit dem etwas sperrigen namen eu
eigenmittel ratifizierungsgesetz
abgesehen vielleicht von den debatten um
unsere grundrechte im chor lockdown bahn
und vielleicht auch der von uns nur von
uns erzwungenen debatte voriges jahr zu
gegen die ezb corona programme im
millionenbereich ist das materiell und
meiner meinung nach auch was die
verfassungswidrigkeit angeht eines der
wichtigsten themen überhaupt und das
wird weit über diese legislatur
hinausreichen
aus dem grund wir haben ja auch so
angekündigt werden wir auch
verfassungsklage organ klage einreichen
die wir ihnen heute auch vorstellen
ich möchte ein bisschen ausholen die
debatte heute anekdotisch jetzt wurde
skandalöserweise auf 30 minuten verkürzt
war ursprünglich auf 60 minuten in der
primetime heute angesetzt es war zwar
eine regierungserklärung die das jetzt
verdrängt hat aber einiger formell über
östlichen mittelmeerraum und digitale
zukunft dieses thema ist definitiv
wichtiger als das was eben besprochen
wurde auch wenn es natürlich zu corona
debatten verwendet wurde und so weiter
grundrechte geht ist
das einzige was noch über diesem thema
steht rein materiell sprechen wir von
offiziell 750 milliarden faktisch sind
es wenn man die inflationierung raus
nimmt ihr die eu nimmt 850 milliarden
ein sogenanntes corona programm ist ganz
bewusst so genannt komplett auf schulden
finanziert und zwar erstmals auf eu
verschuldungs basis das heißt die eu
wird hier ganz offiziell zum schulden
nehmer zum kreditnehmer was sie und das
ist schon der erste verfassungsbruch
niemals hätte werden dürfen das ist
expressis verbis in den eu-verträgen
verboten
schon seit vielen jahren eigentlich
schon seit maastricht 1992 und auch
jetzt natürlich im aktuellen uv kollege
glaser der das mit mir gemeinsam
ausgearbeitet hat mit unserem
prozessvertreter natürlich wird dann
auch noch etwas genauer darauf eingehen
wir haben immer viel zu wenig debatten
zeit gehabt für dieses gesetz schon die
erste lesung war sehr kurz und dann im
haushaltsausschuss eine einzige debatte
man hat klasse und ich mussten uns erst
gestern gestern wohlgemerkt erst murren
anschauen als wie ein wenig aus holten
so wie ich das jetzt auch machen mussten
schon nach zehn minuten wollten die
anderen gar nicht mehr darüber reden
weil mehr letzten endes zustimmen will
natürlich gab es auch eine und mit etwas
gutem bilden zwei sachverständigen
anhörung aber wer diese dinge kennt weiß
dass sachverständige exakt das sagen was
auftraggebenden fraktionen in so mit
schreiben also die debatte wurde er mehr
oder weniger dann beendet immerhin nach
zwei stunden aber es gab natürlich
keinen konsens und die einzige fraktion
die wirklich ganz klar eindeutig gegen
dieses heutige gesetz stimmen wird ist
die fraktion
wir rechnen mit zustimmung von union spd
grünen enthaltung der linken aus anderen
gründen
und ja das müssen wir mal abwarten was
die fdp hier macht rechnet nicht mit
einer ablehnung wenn es schlecht läuft
wird sogar zugestimmt was der fdp
allerdings sehr schlecht ein stünde es
ist ein historischer gesetzentwurf
markiert den letzten schritt in die eu
fiskalunion das ist eben die haftung die
haftungsgemeinschaft diesen artikel 125
verträge niemals hätte geben dürfen
das wurde 1990 ganz klar
geschäftsgrundlage a92 den ganzen 90er
jahren es wurde plakatiert herr glaser
hat eben
das tag gesagt an jedem ast 1990 98 vor
der einführung des bundestages das genau
das niemals passieren dürfte kohl hat
stein und bein geschworen dass genau das
nicht passiert ist ist jetzt offiziell
so dass er noch keine eu bei uns durch
die hintertür es ist sind eu bonds durch
die vordertür eu-anleihen verschuldung
und das eröffnet der eu ein völlig neues
feld
sie ist jetzt finanziert wie ein staat
budgetiert wie ein start und ich
prognostiziere dass diese sogenannte
korona programm das der formellen nur
drei jahre investiert werden darf bis
2026 in irgendeiner weise auch eine
fortsetzung finden wird dann das ist
aber heute noch spekulationen aber wenn
einmal so viel geld auf dem tisch liegt
dann wird es irgendwann auch kapituliert
auch wenn wir das bmf das gestern noch
bestritten hat und die zweite
geschäftsgrundlage des euro war
natürlich keine kreditfinanzierung und
keine haftungsgemeinschaft
es steht aber im heutigen gesetz im
artikel 9 ganz klar drin dass im falle
des ausfalls eines staates die anderen
das heißt in der praxis in aller regel
deutschland diese mittel übernehmen wird
und wir leben von 750 bzw
ich spreche ganz bewusst von 850
milliarden das ist die größenordnung des
heutigen programms das ist also die
transfergemeinschaft das no bail out
gebot wird hier eindeutig gebrochen und
es wird dann gleich gewaltig gebrochen
es wird von einer begrenzten
einzelermächtigung gespür gesprochen was
juristisch relevant ist weil das
verfassungsgericht das immer wieder zur
grenze erklärt hat begrenzten
einzelermächtigung heißt zeitlich
begrenzt und auch von der größenordnung
auf einen konkreten zweck begrenzt das
wird formaljuristisch behauptet nur
corona ausgaben und zeitlich begrenzt
wohlgemerkt mit tilgung bis 2058 das ist
die begrenzung wir uns uns die regierung
hier weiß machen die eu der eu rat und
eu-kommission uns weismachen will das
ist ein schlechter witz
es ist ein dammbruch und wenn so was
geschieht dann wird es auch immer wieder
geschehen
also es ist wirklich
ein skandal in vielerlei hinsicht und es
wird hier natürlich die haushaltshoheit
künftiger deutscher bundestage tangiert
auch das ist juristisch hoch relevant
hier wird letzten endes und das steht im
lissabon urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts von 2009 ganz
klar drin ein unveräußerlicher
kernbestand unserer nationalen
souveränität aufgegeben das ist eben die
wahrheit über einnahmen und ausgaben die
dieser bundestag wenn es denn heute
schlecht läuft und es wird schlecht
laufen preisgibt und zwar nicht nur für
diesen bundestag der er bald sein ende
erreicht sondern auch für den 20 21
bis zum dreißigsten bundestag ist
wahrscheinlicher dann irgendwann in 2000
60er jahren dann immer wieder ist von
corona programm die rede das war die
begründung für das gesamte schulden
programm
natürlich sollte man meinen der gesunde
menschenverstand und auch juristisch ist
das im konnexitätsprinzip festgehalten
auch ein etabliertes rechtsprinzip
dürften diese mittel dann auch nur für
corona direkte kona schäden und corona
folgeschäden meinetwegen noch verwendet
werden das wird aber sowohl von der
bundesregierung in deutschland selbst
als auch von der eu kommission als auch
von sämtlichen eu staaten davon sehr
viel geld bekommen mitteilen alleine
ungefähr 200 milliarden in griechenland
in ähnlicher größenordnung heute schon
komplett negiert es wird noch nicht mal
mehr der versuch unternommen haben es
versucht im haushaltsausschuss raus zu
bekommen und es wurde noch nicht mal der
klägliche versuch unternommen
irgendwie einen bezug zu corona
herzustellen es wurde ganz offen gesagt
ja das ist ja bei zu fassenden letzten
endes steht auch nirgendwo das ist reine
skoda programms ein bisschen doch wir
sagen weil ja die rechtsgrundlage
artikel 122 ist die angebliche corona
notsituation
dann muss müssen die gelder auch nur und
ausschließlich nur für corona folgen
aufgewendet werden und hier ist jede
schamgrenze gefallen die bundesregierung
warte nicht einmal mehr den anschein
dieser zweckbindung und der konnexität
zu coruna sind zu 400 milliarden sogar
geschenke also über die hälfte sind
keine geschenke mehr bilder unerwartet
noch nicht mal einen rückfluss dieser
gelder der die kriterien dahinter sind
nicht corona bezogen es geht letzten
endes wirtschaftswachstumsraten und
natürlich bekommen die länder die
ohnehin schon vor corona schlecht drauf
waren wirtschaftlich das geld weitgehend
dass sie neben di euro südländer und
frankreich die eu wird damit zum hoch
budgetierten superstaat
es geht hier auch nicht nur um kronach
folgen es gibt eine veränderung des
charakters der eu und nicht nur der
finanzverfassung aber über die
finanzverfassung eben der eu insgesamt
weg von einem staatenbund zu einem
budgetierten staat den es nie der es
niemals sein er sich jemals sein durfte
ein staat mit einem mega budget unserer
ansicht nach wird hier ganz klar der
boden der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung verlassen das ist ein
verfassungsbruch mit ansage und ziemlich
frech wir werden aus diesem grund ist
nicht beim parlamentarischen prozess
belassen wir werden sofort nach dem
beendigung des parlamentarischen
prozesses im bundestag und im bundesrat
also noch vor der endgültigen
ratifizierung des gesetzes nach
karlsruhe ziehen
die organklage ist fertig sie sehen sie
hier ich kann sie heute noch nicht
verteilen wir können ihn aber ein ich
sage mal executive summary schon
überreichen das ist fertig wir werden
auch eine einstweilige anordnung suchen
also vorläufigen rechtsschutz denn
dieses gesetz darf noch nicht einmal vom
bundespräsidenten unterzeichnet werden
ausgefertigt werden
das ist unsere feste überzeugung es ist
eine organklage formalrechtlich keine
verfassungsbeschwerde auch keine
normenkontrollklage wir brauchen auch
keine 25% im bundestag dies wird auf
jeden fall eingereicht
und ja so weit möchte ich mal belassen
fahren wir fahren dort haben wir dann
nachher noch gelegenheit für fragen
vielen dank der vielen dank dann würde
ich an herrn glaser übergeben
herzlichen dank und meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren in der tat handelt es
sich um ein epochales ereignis umso
verblüffender ist die die behandlung
dieses vorgangs in dem man in einer
halben stunde morgen im plenum eine
debatte ansetzt um das boot sicher
bedeutendste ereignis neben profit in
dieser legislaturperiode zu behandeln
das ist schon eine sozusagen anti
parlamentarische verhaltensweise die
allen beschwörungen des parlamentarismus
die ja so anfällig gemacht werden
bei jeder rede egal was diese dieser
parole deutlich zuwiderläuft
ich will das epochale unterstreichen
durch zwei zitate leih mir also die
autorität eines sehr renommierten
professors und zwar ist dass dieser
europa nicht laufen
öffentlich-rechtlicher aus bonn
heerdegen ein sehr bekannter man auch
seit jahrzehnten im cdu mobilität ist
und ja mal vor zwei jahren wer sich
beworben hatte auch um die rolle als
vorsitzender der cdu also auch eine
stimme aus einem blickwinkel eines
außerordentlich seriösen menschen
ich sage ihnen das eine zitat mit dem
europäischen wiederaufbau werden zum
ersten mal in der geschichte erhebliche
mittel über eu anleihen aufgenommen und
an die mitgliedsstaaten verteilt
ein stopp in deutschland steht dass der
haupt haushaltsautonomie des parlaments
allerdings der jetzt geplanten schulen
gemeinschaft entgehen dazu will ich
gleich nur eine eine ausführung machen
will aber zuvor noch mal sagen dass herr
heerdegen ebenfalls sagt wir stehen vor
der größten weichenstellung in der
geschichte der europäischen union seit
einführung des euro es ist gleichzeitig
auch die teuerste veränderung und es ist
gleichzeitig auch der größte bruch
vertraglicher verpflichtungen
zitat ende man kann es plastischer und
besser gar nicht ausdrücken
und wie schon gesagt von der von der aus
dem blickwinkel der wissenschaft also
nicht ein mann des politischen
grabenkampf was der sich hier
artikuliert aber jeder der eindringt die
materie als sicher so viele
parlamentarier gar nicht tun weil es
auch eine sehr schwierige materie ist
das europäische recht ist
außerordentlich steinig und auch soll
ich ihn transparent das ist so eines der
geheimnisse dieses vertragswerks deshalb
ist so auslegungs freundlich und auch so
manipulations freundlich so dieses mal
zuerst zu der fundamentalen bedeutung
ich will dass nur noch mal android was
der kollege bürger aber schon gesagt hat
man beruft sich darauf weil die frage
natürlich steht woher die union
überhaupt die kompetenz was macht die da
da sagt man es gebe einen artikel 122 im
uv und da würde drinstehen dass man in
notlagen einem staat helfen kann
ja das stimmt das aber erkennbar eine
singuläre aktion für ein einzel start
und da vielleicht auch eingestanden
gruppe die in irgendeiner weise vom
meteoriten einschlag oder von tsunami
oder von was immer betroffen seien aber
eine pandemie ist bekanntlich
definitorischen etwas was alle betrifft
nämlich auch ganz europa also kann es
keine sonderbelastungen von einzelnen
staaten gehen
ergo kann der 122 der ganze leid idee
gar nicht funktionieren
und das zweite ist in der tat dass das
konstrukt so raffiniert gemacht ist dass
man die schulden auf eu konto aufnimmt
und die tilgung nachher über die
beiträge der mitgliedstaaten die
sozusagen in späteren jahren jährlich zu
den haushalten geleistet werden dass man
da die schulden tilgt also schuldner und
tilgen gefallen gewissermaßen mindestens
wirtschaftlich auseinander und von daher
gesehen entsteht eben der mechanismus
dass die staaten die hohe beiträge
zahlen die hohen tilgung lasten tragen
und dass die staaten die eben geringe
beiträge zahlen sehr gering betroffen
sind und diese diese struktur ist
geradezu invers gegenüber der struktur
der verteilung der mittel
das heißt die mittel werden genau danach
verteilt wer hat ein geringes budget und
wer hat eine hohe arbeitslosigkeit und
das bezogen auf einen zeitraum von kogit
das heißt also es gibt überhaupt gar
keinen zusammenhang der hergestellt wird
für sie sicher auch optisch nach dem
motto wir haben kobe kobe problem müssen
wir lösen ergo ist ein problem das uns
alle angeht also müssen wir das alle
lösen die verteilungs kriterien neben
überhaupt kein bedarf
und das zweite ist dass auch die mittel
die nachher ausgeteilt werden
von ihren von ihren verwendungszwecken
hier definiert werden zu etwa 60 prozent
mit digitalisierung und green deal von
gesundheit und von kogit kommt da gar
nichts vor
das heißt also auch die verwendung der
ungleichmäßig verteilten mittel hat
wiederum nichts mit vw zu tun sondern
eine reine für wirtschafts
stützungsmaßnahmen für ein europa das am
rande des wirtschaftlichen
zusammenbruchs ist
wir haben eine verschuldung in europa im
durchschnitt von über 100 prozent der
staaten
sie kennen das stabilitätskriterium des
bundes stabilitätskriterium dass die 60
fest schreibt und wir wissen etwa wieder
zusammengestellt von einem wunderbaren
bericht des bundesrechnungshof aus
diesen tagen das seit 99 bei dem
kriterium der schuldenstandsquote mal
weit mehr als in der hälfte der fälle
die verträgt vertraglichen pflichten
nicht eingehalten 59 prozent der fälle
die jährlich ja zu bewerten sind hast du
land xy seine schuldenquote 61 und
gründet 60 prozent der fälle war das
nicht der fall
seit wir uns im gemeinsamen euro
befinden dass ähnliche gilt über das
defizitkriterium also die nicht das
verbot die drei prozent jährliche
defizite in der haushalts abwicklung zu
entscheiden
das sind 109 fälle 40 prozent in 40
prozent der fälle sagt dieses kriterium
nicht eingehalten und was ebenfalls noch
von großer bedeutung ist der europäische
gericht der europäische rechnungshof hat
dieser tage mal zahlen vorgelegt dazu
wie weit sich die staaten an die
empfehlungen der eu kommission halten
bei ihrer gestaltung ihrer
wirtschaftlichen und finanziellen
verhältnisse also im sogenannten
semester werden solche empfehlungen den
staaten gemacht und die spannende frage
ist immer wer hält sich der zahlung wenn
sich nicht daran und ich kann ihm
mitteilen dass der rechnungshof soeben
gesagt dazu in 75 prozent der fälle
halten sie sich zum teil oder gänzlichen
die staaten an das was vorgegeben ist
das heißt wenn sie also jetzt hören
die eu macht ja jetzt pläne die fordert
ja von jedem land jetzt den ein und sagt
da müsste er ein schreiben was er macht
und wir werden das begutachten oder
wären wir ganz groß und streng darauf
achten dass das eingehalten wird meine
damen und herren
man kann es einfach nicht anders sagen
so weit man wachsen ist eine gewisse
lebenserfahrung hat davon wird nichts
eingehalten sondern wir marschieren in
einem weiteren schulden aufbauen
und wenn der finanzminister sagt das
beste was wir gegen für die resilienz
also sozusagen die widerstandsfähigkeit
von volkswirtschaften tun können ein
lieblingswort dass in jedem satz einmal
vorkommt in jedem schriftstück der eu
zehnmal restschulden für die resilienz
meine tante das ist dass das ist die
logik wir müssen jetzt also riesen
schulden machen das hat sei eine
kraftvolle antwort auf cupid sagt der
finanzminister dieses landes das ist
geradezu als im kabarett das ist
wirklich aus dem kabarett ist gegen jede
menschliche vernunft und deshalb wollen
wir sie auch die öffentlichkeit
mobilisieren dahingehend dass das was
hier geschieht in abenteuerliche
konsequenzen führen wird ich will gerne
noch einmal vorzeigen das berühmte
merkel zitat das einfach zu schön ist
eine gesamtschuldnerische haftung für
die in europa nicht statt so lange ich
lebe
es ist einfach zu schön als dass man es
nicht zeigt das ist sozusagen eine art
grundsätzliche aussage der
staatskanzleien und der weltpolitik
merkel und im artikel 9 absatz 5 dieses
eigenmittel beschluss steht genau das
gegenteil drücken wenn ein teil der
staaten ihre schulden nicht bedient dann
kann die eu-kommission andere staaten
dafür in anspruch nehmen und das wird
also mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit geschehen dann noch
einmal dieses berühmte plakat und die
parole dazu die ich mich natürlich
lebendig erinnerung alle die sich noch
erinnern 99 ein paar tage zurück aber es
ist eine ganz kurze frist von jeweils 99
sie haben wir vorhin schon gehört das
instrument endlich
die eu sei von bis 20 58 und das sei
einfach untergehen das instrument also
in 40 jahre vorübergehend sind dann ist
auch die zeit distanz von jetzt nach 99
zum europawahlkampf ist vorübergehend
ist also nur kurzen strecke da hat die
cdu in jedem alle laternen was das
plakat gehängt weil in der bevölkerung
anlässlich der euro schaffung die angst
umging dass das zur schon juni und
führen würde wie klug sind die leute auf
der straße dann hat die cdu versucht die
cabane dagegen zu fahren wie vor ist
alles geregelt wir haben tolle verträge
gemacht
und letztens letztens hier angekündigt
noch einen satz zu dem was herr
heerdegen sagt wo ist das
verfassungsrechtliche probleme zu
europarechtlichen habe ich was gesagt
dass verfassungsrechtlich nicht darin
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
anschließen
anlässlich der schaffung dieses
sogenannten esm european security mehr
gelesen dass geschaffen worden ist im
zusammenhang mit der griechenland-krise
das ja ebenfalls eine kleine schulden
fasziniert darstellt das aber immerhin
so ähnlich wie der internationale
währungsfond geld der verkippt gegen
auflagen natürlich nicht nur gegen die
auflage zu zahlen klar sondern auch du
musst damit das und das machen stichwort
griechenland und stichwort kommission in
griechenland dann prüft machen die denn
das was sie eigentlich da machen sollen
und als dieser vertrag unterschrieben
worden ist auch hier da unten einhellig
abgedeckt worden ist im parlament wurde
dagegen geklagt
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt
wenn ihr gar nicht wisst welche
verpflichtungen aus der vertrag
schließung das ist ein eigener guter
mentaler vertrag der esm-vertrag welche
verpflichtungen daraus erwachsen
dann dürft ihr diesen vertrag nicht
zustimmen weil damit die budgethoheit
des deutschen bundestages sozusagen
unzulässig eingeschränkt ist und wenn
das geschieht ist die staatlichkeit per
se ein geschenk zum element der
staatlichkeit der bundesregierung
deutschland 79 3 gehört nicht nur der
föderalismus und die menschenrechte
sondern es gehört auch so etwas
wie eine fundamentale eigenbestimmung
der eigenen bevölkerung durch wahlen auf
das parlament die eigenen finanzen das
eigene schicksal dieses staates zu
bestimmen
das steckt hinter dem budget und das hat
daher gegen völlig zu recht diese
rechtsprechung die damals im nicht dazu
führte dass neu verhandelt werden musste
obwohl schon beschlossen war und eine
protokoll dem vertrag angefügt wurde in
dem drinsteht dass der esm keine eigenen
hebelung machen kann das heißt also
nicht selbst sich geld beschaffen kann
durch eigene schuldenaufnahmen die dann
in eine haftung zurückschlagen auf die
nationalstaaten und genau das haben wir
hier dass wir eben befürchten müssen
dass in unbegrenzter höhe mindestens mal
bis 800 milliarden rechnerisch möglich
verpflichtungen entstehen wir alle gibt
gar nicht kennen die kennen wir nicht
und das verhalten dritter
ob sie tilgen oder nicht tilgen ob sie
erklären wir wollen aber nicht mehr
tilgen da steht extra ausdrücklich im
vertrag drin wenn die erklären sie
können nicht tilgen
dann kann die eu kommission sagen ich
nehme mir einen anderen schulter nimmt
einen schuldner mit einer besseren
bonität und dreimal dürfen sie raten wir
das sein wird ja sie haben richtig
geraten und dann heißt das dass kann
sich da auf addieren bis auf diese 18
milliarden und das können sie sich
vorstellen die sind zwei bundeshaushalte
vom volumen das schmeißt uns natürlich
aus der bahn
das heißt es ist liegt für jeden der ein
bisschen was von den dingen versteht auf
der straße wer diesen weg geht wird auch
diesen verfassungsverstoß begehen und
die kaltschnäuzigkeit wie das geschieht
morgen in einer halben stunde
sie werden feiertags reden hören wir
werden dann eine namentliche abstimmung
machen
namentliche abstimmung hat den nachteil
dass natürlich auch die mitglieder des
bundestags sich ihrer eigenen partei
gegenüber alten müssen wie sie wirklich
denken kann man sagen war vielleicht
nicht genug dass wir das gemacht haben
aber es ist wie es ist für die
geschichte ist gewahrt werde diesen weg
geöffnet hat und wer sich dagegen
gestemmt hat und unsere antwort zu
dieser frage ist völlig klar
herzlichen dank
boehringer wollte noch etwas hinzufügen
ja das geht jetzt sehr schnell aber es
passt sehr gut und ich bin das auch noch
schuldig geblieben ohnehin wäre das noch
in den fragen gekommen denke ich
ergänzend hat leider hat klar so hat
eben schon die verletzten
grundprinzipien dieser republik
rechtsstaatlich und demokratisch genannt
das ist auch tatsächlich als war ein
zitat heerdegen von gestern oder
vorgestern
wir haben das natürlich in unserer
organklage auch tatsächlich aufgreifen
müssen also hier geht es absolut 1
gemacht denn die substanz dieser
republik unser prozessvertreter ist
professor schachtschneider damit ja
schon regelmäßig zu tun hat aber selbst
er hat diese kombination von
rechtsverletzungen auf abstrakter ebene
noch selten erlebt also wir reden hier
klasse hat es teilweise schon genannt
von der natürlichen der
haushaltspolitische gesamtverantwortung
des ist ein geltender wichtiger
rechtsgrundsatz des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes reden von der
integrationsverantwortung der
bundesregierung und auch des bundestages
zivi verletzt sehen
wir reden von der in identität des
grundgesetzes ist jetzt abstrakt muss
nicht jeder sofort verstehen aber wir
reden von der souveränität deutschlands
letzten endes wir reden vom
demokratischen prinzip und vom
konnexitätsprinzip was ich auch schon
genannt hatte weil die kausale zuordnung
der zahlung eben nicht auf cobit ausgabe
gründe
nicht in ordnung ist also das ist
wirklich ruhe ist juristisches trapez
und es ist erforderlich weil alles das
verletzt wird durch dieses vorliegen die
gesetze hier wird wirklich also das
budgetrecht ist ja nicht umsonst das
königsrecht des deutschen bundestages
ist nach artikel 110 grundgesetz und es
wird hier ein weiteres mal ausgehöhlt
und diesmal ziemlich gründlich noch
einen ganz anderen größenordnung als
damals vor zehn jahren bei mir es im
urteil wird es im gesetz 2012 das wird
teilweise auch bezug nehmen schneider
hatte deshalb tatsächlich mit uns
zusammen über 150 seiten klageschrift
schreiben müssen
die können wir in der
kurzzusammenfassung auch zur verfügung
stellen
die rechtsgrundlagen hat ja gerade schon
genannt die hier unser unseres erachtens
falsch angewandt wurden oder
unzutreffend nicht einschlägig
insbesondere sind artikel 310 311 ich
will sich einmal nennen nicht
einschlägig derartige 125 ist verletzt
dass das no bail out gebot der artikel
136 des eben nicht genannt hat aber auch
sehr relevant ist hat damals 2012
nachträglich die kreditaufnahme durch
den esm europäischer
stabilitätsmechanismus noch legitimiert
es war erforderlich das zu tun weil
damals jedem rechtsgelehrten klar war
dass diebe vorhandenen artikel nämlich
die auch heute noch bestehende artikel
trainer 10 311 122 eben nicht
ausreichend für eine europäische
schulden aufnahme noch nicht mal für
einen nachgelagert das vehikel
geschweige denn für die kommission
selbst das war damals klar der 136 hat
das jetzt auch nicht erhalt das nur für
den esm
das heißt allenfalls müsste mir jetzt
noch einen ähnlichen artikeln
nachschieben der europäischen verträge
ähnlich wie damals 136 2012 was aber
nicht geplant ist das wäre primär
rechtsänderung das davor scheut sich die
bundesregierung versucht das jetzt mit
einem einfachen ratifizierungsgesetz es
gibt sogar streit darum ob 50 prozent an
zwei drittel braucht ich fürchte wir
werden heute sogar zwei drittel bekommen
das hängt einen einzelnen fraktionen
heute aber das werden wir dann sehen ob
die zustande kommen aber setzt die zwei
drittel würden nicht die europäische
premiere rechtsänderung begründen die
herforder ich wäre denn sie liegt ja
heute gar nicht auf dem tisch also das
sind schon wichtige dinge
der prozess um das noch einmal formal zu
sagen den wir
müssen wird durch die fdp fraktion als
organ des deutschen bundestages geführt
gegen die deutsche bundesregierung der
nachlässigkeiten vorwerfen also sprich
nicht handeln
es ist ein richtig keit klage gemäß
artikel 2 163 euro vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof geplant aber diese wird er
organklage natürlich wie immer gemäß §
264 bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz sein
da klagen wir in prozessstandschaft als
organ gegen die regierung und sogar in
deutschen bundestag wegen dessen
nachlässigkeiten die sich die sich heute
zeigen werden im haus also das noch
nachgereicht wird es wahrscheinlich
sowieso gefragt worden wäre
herr schmidt ja
damit haben sie in der tat schon fragen
beantwortet zwei weitere fragen wie
bewerten sie die erfolgsaussichten und
die dauer des verfahrens ist die eine
und die andere gibt es zumindest
inoffiziell signale der unterstützung
von mdb es aus anderen fraktionen die
dauer vor gericht ist mir auf hoher see
wir hatten ja eine organklage jetzt in
den mindestens ebenso wichtigen
verfahren im august 2020 eingereicht
gegen das programm der ezb mit ähnlichem
ansatz prozessstandschaft des deutschen
bundestages bis jetzt ist die mündliche
verhandlung noch nicht in sicht damals
hatten wir allerdings auch tatsächlich
keine keinen vorläufigen rechtsschutz
angemeldet das ist diesmal anders
wir werden also auch eine einstweilige
anordnung mit einreichen sofort ja
wahrscheinlich noch diese woche
das ist auch notwendig weil ich fordere
hier auch öffentlich den
bundespräsidenten auf dieses gesetz
nicht auszufertigen nicht zu
unterzeichnen bevor diese einstweilige
ordnung gebracht nun geprüft ist aber
eigentlich sogar das hauptsacheverfahren
abwarten
natürlich ist das schon ein gewisser
schlag ins kontor wenn das so kommt es
ist aber dieses in dieser legislatur
schon mal so gekommen also der
bundespräsident hat schon mindestens ein
vielleicht sogar zwei gesetze nicht
direkt ausgefertigt es muss
nachgebessert werden
schauen wir mal wie es hier kommt
natürlich ist es nicht einfach weil
dieses gesetz ungefähr 25 staaten in
europa gleichlautend vorliegt aber es
muss sein hier ist gefahr im verzug in
riesiger größenordnung hier dürfen keine
fakten geschaffen werden durch den
bundespräsidenten denn danach geht das
seine europäischen sozialisten
mit sozialistischen gang und das wollen
wir nicht die zweite frage war ob wir
unterstützung von anderen tja da schon
vorsichtig formuliert von fraktionen
erwarten sie schon gar nicht mehr ich
erwarte jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
in die abstimmung im haushaltsausschuss
gestern verlief tatsächlich so dass sich
außer den linken niemand enthalten hat
alle anderen fraktionen haben zugestimmt
damit stünde die sogar die
zweidrittelmehrheit wenn das heute im
plenum sich wiederholt nur die afg hat
dagegen gestimmt was ich erwartet in
einzelne artikel 31 erklärungen nach der
geschäftsordnung des bundestages wonach
einzelne die namentliche abstimmung und
nach einzelne mdb sich erklären können
warum sie so abgestimmt haben und da
wird es sicher wortreiche
exkommunikationen geben von einzelnen
kollegen speziell vermute ich der fdp ja
vielleicht auch von anderen fraktionen
auch der union die erklären werden warum
es eigentlich nicht gut finden wie hier
ab ihre fraktionen abgestimmt hat aber
warum sie
oder warum sie trotzdem mit stimmen
mussten und sie werden dann auch
absetzte weise daran setzen im
übergeordneten europäischen interesse
ist es dann doch nötig und irgendwas
ausnahme falls der pandemie sei es dann
doch nötig trotzdem hält das all das
nicht die rechtsbrüche die heute
stattfinden werden und deshalb finde ich
eine artikel 31 erklärung heute die ich
durchaus erwarte von einigen kollegen
nicht ausreichend man muss hier mit nein
stimmen alles andere ist vor der
geschichte nicht verantwortbaren und vor
dem rechtsstaat auch nicht gut
weitere fragen mich jetzt im moment
nicht vorliegen wenn es von ihrer seite
noch klar informationsstand ist noch
drei bemerken gerne machen wollen weil
ja die schulden aufnehmen dadurch
relativiert wird dass man jetzt sagt
habe die eu hat ja doch da schon immer
mal da und dort immer ein paar schulden
aufgenommen und einen rechtlich
unselbstständig das institut einer
entwicklungsbank in europa würde das
auch tun so nach dem motto ja cosi fan
tutte würde man fast sagen wir mal die
garage wäre also der ladendieb sagt ja
auch immer die anderen machen es auch
alle und werden auch nicht erwischt also
informant ist natürlich eine etwas
irrwitzige argumentation ich will aber
dazu nochmal ebenfalls ein zitat von ein
herr degen dazu
noch vor einem jahr herrschte nicht nur
in der rechtswissenschaft sondern auch
in den meisten europäischen hauptstädten
die ansicht vor dass die europäischen
verträge die beanspruchte kompetenz zur
schuldenfinanzierung der eu nicht
hergeben
auch der grundsatz des ausgeglichenen
haushaltes steht der
schuldenfinanzierung durch zuwendungen
entgegen externe einnahmen aus krediten
gehören nicht zu den eigenmitteln aus
denen sich die eu zu finanzieren hat
eine ähnliche auskunft zu dieser
berühmten frage dürfen darf die eu
kritiker auf dem darf sie das eigentlich
gar nicht eine fundamentale frage die
man ja eigentlich nur mit ja oder mit
nein beantworten kann
dazu gibt es am 30 3 26 15
gibt es eine antwort der kommission an
einen anfragenden eu-parlamentarier denn
diese frage auch drückte und der deshalb
auch die frage gestellt hat die
eu-kommission hat geantwortet ich
zitiere was die verpflichtung zum
ausgleich des eu-haushaltes anbelangt so
lautet die übereinstimmende auslegung
dieses artikels gemeint ist der artikel
311 ev dass der eu haushalt nicht durch
ausgabe von staatsschulden ausgeglichen
werden kann
zitat ende das war also übereinstimmende
rechtsmeinung bis vorgestern
man kann die frage auftaucht bleibt
vielleicht auch den einen oder anderen
zuschauer zu hören
ja wir haben die das hingekriegt dass
das irgendwie gar nicht gemacht wird ja
das ist eine hoch interessante frage und
ich kann ihnen mitteilen
viele von uns sage ich ja sich bemüht
haben sehr viele juristische themen tief
einzuarbeiten
da werden kunstwerke geboren
da gibt es eben beispielsweise gutachten
der rechts stelle des europäischen rates
da fällt einem als jurist ein so nach
dem motto der chef hat gesagt wir wollen
folgendes machen jetzt musst du mir aus
dem rechtsaußen justiziariat behält sich
rechtliche begründung dafür liefern so
liest sich das wenn sie den text lesen
ich kann das hier nicht nachstellen
die kunstvollen konstruktionen aber eine
konstruktion darf ich vielleicht an
leuten ist die diese mittel die da jetzt
fließen in den nächsten zwei jahren
diese 750 vielleicht bis 800 bis 2024
geht milliarden an mitteln design da
nicht haushaltsmittel sondern das sei
eine art sonderposten der allerdings
nicht im haushaltsrecht irgendwo so
vorgibt so nach dem motto du darfst auch
neben dem haushalt der haushalt der eu
so zwischen 130 und 150 milliarden
du darfst neben dem haushalt darfst du
noch gelder ausgeben die doppelt oder
dreimal soviel sind pro jahr wie im
haushalt selber das ist dann nicht
haushalt sondern irgendetwas anderes und
da es etwas anderes ist haben wir doch
das verbot den haushalt mit krediten zu
finanzieren dem aber gar nicht
widersprochen
gemeiner also das haben gar nicht
übertrieben das wird dort dargestellt in
einer sagen wir mal komplizierten
rechtssprache so nach dem motto wir
haben uns ein loch geschaffen
britta legal geld auszugeben und das
brettl egal ausgegebene geld zu
finanzieren können auch eine breite
legale einnahmen behalten ist ganz
einfach so so etwa auf diesem niveau
wird versucht das zu recht zu zwicken
und dazu lassen sie mich nur als letztes
sagen weil parlamentarismus ist ja in
aller munde meine damen und herren
diese frage ist entschieden worden in
einem telefongespräch zwischen der
kanzlerin und der eu
kommissionspräsident in und alles was
wir seither erleben ist eigentlich nur
das schlepper tragen von parlamenten für
leitfiguren
es ist also ein beschämender vorgang
wenn man es nicht vorstellen dass eben
demokratie mit parlament was zu tun hat
das muss man analytisch einfach nur so
sagen will sie die abläufe sehen ab dem
tag wo dieses telefon war war nur noch
die frage wie kriegen wir die parlamente
zur gefolgschaft und wie kriegen wir die
staaten bei denen ein paar staatsmänner
noch dabei sind sie sagen so kann das
alles nicht gehen sie kennen die
berühmten holland finnland dänemark und
andere
die kriegen wir dann und das ist so
gemacht worden wie wir wissen
dadurch dass man ihnen an droht dass man
eben sperrt dass man sie von der großen
quelle der eu-fonds die es ja gibt in
vielfältiger weise von agrar bis zur bis
zur strukturverbesserung wenn man also
dort druck ausüben will dann kann man
das dann kann die kommission sagen so
und wenn ihr nicht marschiert als land a
oder b oder c dann werdet ihr das zu
spüren bekommen und wir können ihnen
glaube ich einigermaßen gesichert mit
allen genauso wird dort gespielt genauso
werden dort mehrheiten beschafft genauso
wie dort der parlamentarismus
ausgehebelt
vielen dank
klar sei dass keine weiteren
wortmeldungen fragen gibt dann danke ich
für interesse und wünschen noch einen
schönen tag
vielen dank